look who stopped by Dale Earnhardt jr.
part of NBC's crew for the Superbowl and
the Olympics been all over the place
good to see you yes it's uh it's the
youth it's gonna be a pretty fun weekend
okay what did you do yesterday you were
doing outdoor outdoor activity yeah so
yesterday we were putting together a bit
for that we're gonna run during the
pregame stuff and it was me and Rutledge
and we were we're kind of like in the
outdoors checking out some of the
activities and and things some of the
sports and stuff that fans are people
that live around Minnesota getting their
shows involved and there's this thing
called broom ball that was probably the
funnest thing that I thought we did and
basically it it it's on a a miniature
ice rink hockey rink
there's goals there's you know there's
five guys on each team and it started
with these brooms they dipped in wax and
it's about the you batting around this
half-size soccer ball and yes it's it
was real fun you the the ice he wear his
tennis shoes so the ice is a bit of a it
levels the playing field you know
there's there were no nobody out there
just you know dominate did you get
injured no I actually didn't follow then
but we fell a lot and I got injured when
we did something called scheduling where
you put on which I just learned how to
ski over the New Year's holiday just
recently so you put on these
cross-country skis and you strap
yourself to a greyhound and you're they
just kind of drag you around this track
so that was a lot of fun once you get
going it's pretty good but once when
you're taking off the dogs like can drag
you you know
he'll drag you along if he wants to so I
felt quite a bit then but what a great
day a lot of fun we're gonna have
coverage of this on Super Bowl Sunday
and I know that you just wanted to stop
by to see the set and you know we'll see
you won Super Bowl Sunday are you
enjoying retirement I was I wasn't
expecting to be as busy as I am but I
haven't it feels like that I hadn't
stopped her
I haven't had a day off since I got
married and that was almost a year and a
month or two ago so because baby on the
way yeah I got a baby coming in May and
so just so much so much going on so much
happening I had no idea like when I got
out of the car what life was gonna be
like what I was going to do I really
enjoyed being you know a part of
something in Motorsports and in racing
and I needed to feel that you know
feeling as I go into this next chapter
being a part of a team being an asset to
something being valuable to something so
I went into the booth a couple times in
2016 and I went in there just to check
this box is this something I want to do
something that would excite me or
something that I might be able to do
after driving because I knew my racing
career was coming to an end and I had so
much fun I was only in this booth at
these races for a couple hours and then
I did the entire clash it started season
last year but I had come out of there
on cloud nine so much fun in there
talking racing and just telling people
what you're seeing it was so fun and so
I was thinking that's it this checks all
the boxes this is going to be something
that'll keep me in the sport and a way
for me to help the sport or I don't care
if I'm just helping it this much or you
know a lot I just want to be a part of
its growth you know and I want to be
involved in it and and tell people about
it so this is gonna be such a great
opportunity it's great it's great to see
you more of a junior coming up on Sunday
on NBC we by the way it's meet Friday we
do have some ribs saw that yeah it's
pretty good this is this is really one
here I don't blame you take Rutledge
wood and go get a plate there for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you